all right let's go next to um isaac from
wyoming isaac welcome
hi can you hear me yes i can
all right uh i wanted to talk about the
cynthia loomis speech uh i know this
happened a couple weeks ago yeah so for
people who don't know let me catch them
up if i can just so everybody knows
cynthia loomis wyoming senator spoke at
the commencement ceremony of university
of wyoming and uh she she brought up you
know she was sort of anti-trans in the
speech and we talked about it
right and you had mentioned in the
beginning of the video that you didn't
know why she would go to a sort of
transphobic direction
so i kind of wanted to just give my
opinion on that okay
i think
on a national level
it was seen as loomis making a stupid
comment
and yes students booed when she made the
comment about people denying quote
scientific facts about there being two
sexes
um
my thought is this was a well thought
out
and calculated scandal that was uh a
very safe move for her
because these are university of wyoming
graduates many of whom aren't from
wyoming and will move out of state after
graduating she's not worried about their
vote
it's clear to me
that lunas made this con knowing it
would score points with her base
uh while undermining higher education
which i believe the gop is very much
against because
they they don't want the working class
people to be educated absolutely that's
all true
uh loomis
knew
that it would be controversial
and she would be in headlines
um and that the largely uneducated
religious base of wyoming would see it
so she would score points with her base
because now she's seen as exposing
higher education for brainwashing people
into
liberal wokeness right
yeah wyoming is interesting i i've never
been but i would like to i mean how how
rural do you is your circumstance do you
live rurally or in one of the cities
though uh
i live in albany county which is where
the university of wyoming is and
i think because
it's it's where the university of
wyoming is
more liberal type
people
tend to
live in that in this area
um the the other more sort of
liberal area of wyoming would be
around jackson
uh which is you know
it's all you know you got to be really
wealthy to live in jackson but but i
mean in terms of how rural it is you're
you're not in one of these situations
where it's like 20 miles to the grocery
store or anything like that
no no no no
like uh the university of wyoming it is
you would probably consider it like a
smaller town not not like a large city
but yeah yeah there's grocery stores
there's
movie theaters there's a downtown area
that's really great and
lots of towns like that in wyoming it's
not
large largely of
i mean larry's a little old but yeah
can you get a good bagel in wyoming
i mean the supermarkets have bagels
god oh my goodness okay i feel really
bad for you that is what that's that's a
bad answer i mean it's you're not
nothing you're lying like there's like
einstein big ol oh god oh my god i'm
gonna have to let you go okay
okay i feel it wow wyoming i feel sorry
for everybody there okay thank you i
appreciate the call
uh man that is that is disturbing
your choices are einstein brothers
and which actually it's not that bad
actually when i was when i was in
arizona recently i got i had no choice
but at the start of a drive i picked up
an einstein brothers bagel it was i
actually wasn't terrible but um and then
your freezer aisle of supermarket bagels
that's that's pretty tough all right
everybody thank you to everybody who
called in we will take more calls next
week we've got our town hall coming up
on june 14th
and i look forward to talking to more
people we'll take a quick break and be
right back
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below